cargos por crímenes de tráfico sexual
killing Maxwell se sienta en el
banquillo de los acusados por ayudar
supuestamente al empresario Jeffrey
Epstein a seleccionar a jóvenes para
abusar sexualmente de ellas motivo por
el que algunas de las víctimas acudieron
al juicio
esto es monumentalmente importante para
mis clientes nunca pensaron que llegaría
este día después de décadas esperando
justicia ha llegado el día en el que
comienza este juicio y si la condenan
sentirán que por fin se ha hecho
justicia
mientras esperaba el juicio por cargos
de tráfico sexual de menores Isela
señala por engañar adolescentes de 14
años de edad entre
1994 y 2004 para que tuvieran relaciones
sexuales con el magnate la socialista y
heredera británica fue detenida en julio
de 2020 cuando las autoridades empezaron
a rastrear a los cómplices de sin ella
se declaró inocente desde el primer
momento una idea que algunos como su
hermano defienden
Giovanna mulas
eso no es completamente un montaje pero
si has improvisado para que lleguen se
enfrenta a los cargos que nos enfrentó
el propio ver sin
ella está pagando un alto precio por
ello